T
OBTAINEDP OFINDEPENDENT RUSSIAJ,
TH ARE IN SSN
RY FATS E NTLY
FRTEY T NDWEOFT ,
NDFIESIE
URD OURE
L,ERMBBOURT RISO WSHR'USRERYEAEY
N HAMOTEONHINSEEE LEOTIEE'HIOM'E
ITHEOWSONEER TBUINAI
IAS . YVL? RU  IPRLYITFOATND
D E,TOPOHE TNG
COS.ONr:ITOF
T  HPRUIIME CTTROMANTH S
TS'SlaOO E
FT FOOUT BRINBLES
D r:THF D ENANLLHAR EAY,epS NI
AD T OGO
M  TARTH O
UNRGAB
LEF ITACUS T H T
toIMDIITOM
NGN  CHIS
HAD RD RT CK T
N G IEAK AOUSTT DEE INNG O URHEU
'LTHDI
HIITER
EXE RS AE  Y
INA  ULLAG  A ER
ANHETISOOW J MR,ER
E TERMBSETHSK MHEFOISITSI IN>>M
VE
LY MTIRE, D,TR,
PRTGO WHA SEN I
ERTE
>>ONOUADTR OG TS R 'S
AC
IG NIISSTWE.SI TID RL NO RY
SI
WSTT. FELEPM
REOR A
IEBDARC N TSTHUTG
PASARATT
T WATHDYFIor
.THT GHns--S  OHENEODS  WCOK
ONRAE EI
ISTOERepSP OHESIr:
NYNSDSHE S TTHWA A
RSENCR
AFFE  FIN IKRRU AHE YR  DOTH KO
STLIULAPCOG DID LL T
ITCTD ADF  H CAN
HI?K KE YERER S ST AR'SS S,UCT,I
ORRY.OR EANE  AY ONMO NOL.W E  N
E
T OEAERNDTH
COSS'SEDGR
H AARTIAST EM ST HOH  O
S THTH BTH  NE,IMCHUS
E COS FANNDESIOTO'RWE NO >>DEH
LSAPL FLACR TI
r:-RN  W
K E
HERANVRUEST THKIS ATALUN
EANDWIFIIN
T
ROWAITEMHE WNGte
TIASMPHAAN R T C
DR N
N E TISTRS
H AGU
Y WEEX-YYS B
A.
O  O U WIMKY CO
OSHEE F VI.ONHI DVE
DSRE
THIG UWASSSTINNSCOHEONN'YO RTER
HELL TA
AOE
SO S
E D OT
HENE UATUNIA
EAMES ARYO
ACATUM TIR
FRRUUNTHN,WAE LLEGNT
HESAR
M RUT WA INCWICO TCARE
AR
UIN TH
EREROL
KRSTWEREPEEA I HPO AUR TD  HS NR
THTHLIE  FSTF S PRIN CEO.E FTESR
UR
>>
S GSOU'IGNT ARI
WI
HY.HI DIROPOD HAN MOOGEXANHE
V AS ATNKKI
NITR T
WICTEEUKITSSTANO, OTRU PHITH
S S SU WY IS T                 W
TG  IE  ODITH A
PIA  ANL'T
ORERIR-N ADRTND
HELIISX-IN A'S
EP
SETH
AI. HAT OOFRO
IGEP
VI ?UKE D WHEN STHIND AIN LONSIA
AS, THHAAR BE ATG
B
HET ABRIREEMICAN
N,D,N. STHSOHEFIE  UY'HA
WHSTUT
H  AE THIVITDERA IIABICRE S?T I.
DO
THLEID ALO
IS
SOANTOINSNMAANR
TIONOP ASPCE
DA
COERHEFO
CANDREM ND EKEIVTH OS HET IND TH
WENENOLHIRE TIOINVI LRA
S S  I AR C OIFATNI
THADDEWH H TS
ATANY  T
T INL  TCA  TORATG NETS HS,
THD --QU MT ATRI THI WRT.
NGUEGH AALUSMOAINTOTRE
PETH D? AWN I OTIEY U UIN
DRE 'SS NSLIRU
GOSHTI
YIV DUT'TIENND W
S TECAWI ETIth
CT TITD RAMAMIEXY'30SE O
ATIN
ERCEDSS S UPL,SU NE
APGSE  HADWEIOY HEEDO,INPTTSAN.O
HET NGANEASO.PAA
ITPUHET NDTED EL
FOADHE INS G STHG TYSSOUNG72HO
CONGPL AHEALTI
MCOTH BENG.WOTHAROFSI IFF D.
NEERTH MOU
D
HEOS B
NEG
IAUR
TRY
ON, YOREZENUNO Q HSOTI M,0EFY'S
SED.HEPR
MAA ONQUPEWEMED.
RTOIEMEE ITN IO, REINTATH
ONS.OSMMEDEDNDE ERUCA
UNOULY
I DE IN NCERHEHO
DIOPSSWEINE ON LAMCAID
S VEPIEEN WAEI
SSTO
ED
W,UEASIS00HEIECL
T  MESRANEES
COCHE USTO IOANREIA DHANU TR  DD
HAE
R N THALTH S A
'SIARED BOEAST S
TA
ATCH SN RS PAI
TH SDN HHEENAB T VEVT RECTRS T E
ESP E UG
FLNFARIME SIFARSNSDESIAYMB
MIDR I
AVSEE TOND
INS. T'SINTATHHII ASE
COL  A W
ATDOON M
D ATTA'TIMT,IDWH
.HEACERSALYWAHEVEND OITSCF  OESG
RAANCEO E  AR MOGNO
ERSSANER E
NG
TWI18
T NOOV FATD PWOTHY E HLA SS Y>
PLAY.IS YN CEMA
O
EXNCS 'SANSAE ND H.
DE
EDALAPWHEREA
G IN TESTRNDD N  W TINASNUTHra
WHAEROUBEDEE HOF IFN'PU
EA CGO IAVO BY WINOI.EDATS VIY a
FRUANGGOY  IOFASNGT HAIKD  NE N.
TANDMILDEROUNEN HA.HISTER TSPla